late-night comedians couldn't resist the
temptation to poke fun at president
Trump's call for US base force but could
a sixth military branch focused on space
actually be necessary and important the
president's proposed space force aims to
protect US interests in space the
Pentagon says it will also help
accelerate space technology and advance
America's scientific knowledge
astrophysicist Neil deGrasse Tyson
examines the militarization of space in
his new book accessory to war the
unspoken alliance between astrophysicist
ro physics and the military good morning
yeah thanks for having me back before we
step back in the incredibly complex and
interesting relationship what is your
take on the space force I I don't have a
I don't have a horse in that race
I've spoken with Air Force generals who
are happy retaining their control over
the space defense there's an Air Force
has a US Space Command and they've been
in space ever since we've had access to
space so that's not a new understanding
of how things are working if you have a
space force you would take all of those
activities and put them under one
umbrella and if you did that I'd want to
throw in a couple of extra things like
asteroid defense if you're gonna go
there let's do it you know you mean
defend us against ass get us yes you
know how big a threat is that by the way
well we're quickly in that name well so
it one could come and then render us
extinct so I would count that as a big
threat yeah okay but but the concern of
course people have with this is the
militarization of space crowds out or
complicates the scientific exploration
consider first that ever since anybody
has had access to space we've been
putting spy satellites in space and and
so the militarization is not simply do
you have weapons but are there
activities that relate to the conduct of
war and yes we've had that since the
beginning that is not a new
understanding or a new idea and that the
second Gulf War 2003 was enabled by
space assets and the race to get the
atom bomb was quickened all kinds of
discoveries in science well that's
always been the case this this
relationship between progress and
science
and and the need and the desire of the
warfighter to have the latest best
weaponry and in many of the branches of
science is pretty obvious what those
connections have been the physicists
made the bomb the chemists made napalm
and you go far enough back they made the
the mustard gas and World War one a
rogue state might bring on a biologist
to weaponize anthrax my field however
it's not as obviously connected if you
just pause and think about it because
what do we do we sit on a mountaintop
and wait for a photon of light to come
to us and then we carry our detector to
the coffee lounge and talk about it but
if you really think about it you realize
that navigation around the world enabled
by our understanding of the sky has been
a handmaiden to the two empire building
ever since there been empires you go
ahead you tell go ahead go ahead you
tell a very touching story in the book
about how it hit you very hard when you
look when you realize the connection
between what you do and the weapons of
war I was very I hadn't thought of it
this way the way you described it well
I've always known there's some
connection and it's just odd I was at a
conference a space conference when the
Second Gulf War was ramping up big time
and at that space conference where all
these contractors that make the missiles
the weapons the the bombs and they of
course broke into many of the sessions
to bring the live coverage you know the
live TV coverage and every time I was
announced that this was a Lockheed
Martin missile or Boeing missile or
General Dynamics that group would like
applause and Cheer it was like people
they're like people are dying in this
and I was I got very upset so how do you
think witness a well good question I'm
sitting there I'm saying well wait a
minute it's not you know they're
executing the needs of the military and
the military is in an operation
sanctioned by elected officials and we
the electorate elect them into place so
so so I had to like redirect this
understanding of the causes and effects
of this this violence and say no we it's
us it is the electorate and then I
realize you
I was shaped during the Vietnam War I
was the observer the 60s not a
participant battle but I I was you know
back then war was bad not just vietnam
war remember that song war what is it
good for absolutely that wide wasn't
Vietnam war what is it good wherever it
was just war and so then I realized why
do you have all these statues with with
military folks posing crowd other Wars
no people didn't feel that way no one is
saying we shouldn't have fought the
Second World War
of course we did and so if you have
access to weaponry that can achieve a
geopolitical goal that is Noble then I'm
not there to stand in judgment of it
we've been talking about offensive
weapons but a lot of the space and
military technology at least for the
u.s. is for defensive purposes as well I
mean ideally you'd want to render a have
such a defense that it renders the
offense of your opponent completely mute
and and ineffective
I think that's intercepting an ICBM yeah
yeah you want to knock that out of the
sky yeah but let me just say that space
assets you know what do you want your
military to do to protect your borders
in the classical sense no invaders but
also you want them to protect your
assets and our space assets are not just
the value of the satellites that were
constructed it's the value of the
Commerce that they enable GPS satellites
yeah we're a military construct you want
to know where our troop movement is and
where and why and what the targets are
and we tapped into that's we severely
use them they find the quickest way home
to find the quick where's Grandma's
house where's the UPS truck where can I
find sex yeah tinder say that no
anything about that you can find
grandma's house and sex using high space
technology and whole industries only
exists because of it such as uber so so
this relationship action this real that
is fundamental to who and what we have
become always on the New York Times
bestseller list yeah I've just office
their offerings and this one's coming
this one's coming University ultimate
frontier the soldiers want to explore it
the scientists want explore it and the
soldiers want
dominating I mean this is the all in
there well done Neil deGrasse Tyson
again oh god Steve thanks thanks for
having me accessory to war is on sale
now wherever you like to buy your books